foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar HIV
diagnostic testing in the covid-19 era
our clinical laboratories being overly
sensitive
I am Marie Stone of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by bio rad to learn more visit
bio-rad.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers Dr
payu raval pathology resident North
Shore University Health System
Mr Alfredo Villarreal Global product
manager bio rad Laboratories Dr Tom
Alexander Clinical Laboratory director
flow metric Diagnostics
hayu Alfredo and Tom you may now begin
your presentation
hello
I'd like to thank biorad for asking me
to go through this talk my name is Tom
Alexander I've been an immunologist for
many many years and I would like to talk
a little bit about HIV testing stuck in
a rut
my objectives here first of all to talk
about the current available tests then
review the current algorithm for HIV
testing asking the question is it
consistent with the current test
availability so kind of tie those two
together and in a nutshell the answer to
that is going to be no it's not
consistent with the current test
availability so I'll discuss some other
options and kind of plan out for the
future
so most of you probably familiar with
this picture of HIV it's a
double-stranded RNA virus with that is
enveloped the main antigens that we're
measuring antibody against for HIV
testing are the gp41 the GP 120 and the
p24 also the p24 antigen itself is used
in HIV testing as we'll discuss
many HIV diagnostic tests have been
developed over the years and this is
kind of a a slide from a number of years
ago now from 2003 but does a good job of
pointing out some of the differences in
what we can detect and when we can
detect it post infection
so this red bar here shows the initial
first so-called first generation HIV
serology tests that were available in
the mid-1980s they use viral lysates for
their um uh their antigenic targets and
that picked up infection approximately
six weeks post-infection post exposure
the Western blot which was the
confirmatory test at the time also picks
up antibody about five to six weeks so
it was a good confirming test for the
Elisa at that particular time the second
generation added recombinant antigens to
the anagenic mix for the Elisa and
brought the testing window the neck test
negative window down to about four to
five weeks still the Western block gave
a pretty good use as a confirming test
when we went to the third generation
though in the 1990s the we now added IGM
testing to the milieu and IGM testing
now got us down to about three weeks
post-infection but now the Western blot
all of a sudden was not really a useful
confirming test even though it continued
to be used as one because individuals
infected say within three to five or
three to six weeks post exposure and
being tested would test positive on an
Elisa and negative on a western blood
and would be considered to be false
positives so that brought out an idea
that these individuals should probably
be tested again at approx approximately
three to six weeks post their initial
test
RNA the viral load or PCR test would be
positive within one to two weeks
post-exposure the p24 antigen which
during the these Elisa Generations was
being used by the blood banks to help
close the test negative window would
pick up an infection approximately two
weeks post-exposure and symptoms would
occur before an individual would test
positive on anything except a molecular
test so it certainly was possible to
transmit HIV prior to somebody being
positive on a test
this is a slide that I I got from Dr
Michelle Owen at the CDC I thank her for
that and here's the Western blot at the
time that it's positive and now instead
of calling tests by generations for a
second third or fourth generation the
CDC is trying to get down to calling
tests based on how early before the
Western blot a test would be positive so
the current tests that are available are
all over here on the left side of the
graph and they're positive between three
and four weeks earlier than a western
blot would be positive so as you can see
a western blot really would not be a
very good confirming test for the
current generation of screening tests
foreign tests that are out there are
so-called combination or fourth
generation or differentiation or fifth
generation assays so the combination
assays detect both HIV antibody and the
hiv-1 p24 antigen in this combination
reduces the test negative window period
by about a week to two weeks compared to
third generation tests so now we can
pick up an infected individual two weeks
post infection however this test does
not differentiate between HIV antibody
and HIV antigen you get one positive
result and you can't don't know that was
due to the presence of antibody or
antigen
so that brought out the idea of doing
separate antigen and antibody tests and
that's the fifth generation or so-called
differentiation assays and here you get
separate antibody and antigen results
examples of this are the bio RADS
bioplex 2200 HIV antigen antibody acid
this test actually differentiates hiv-1
antibody from HIV to antibody plus gives
you separate antigen results
the Roche HIV Duo test gives you
combined antibody you get one antibody
result with separate antigen results as
does the Abbott determine hiv-1 antigen
antibody combination you get one
antibody result for HIV one and two
which does not differentiate them and
then you get a separate result for the
antigen this is a rapid test
this is a slide from a paper I published
a number of years ago now on different
HIV testing methods but the only thing I
want you really to look at here is the
negative window time here going from
eight to ten weeks in the first
generation test now in the combination
of differentiation or fourth and fifth
generation we're now down to two weeks
post exposure where we can pick up
somebody who is truly infected with HIV
the use of self-testing for covet has
brought up the question is the code
really a model for HIV testing could we
have self-testing home testing if you
will available for HIV well the answer
is we already have it the oral fluid
test the order Shear test is available
and can be done at home has a
sensitivity of about 93 percent for home
use in 99 for laboratory use so it's not
quite as good for home use as it is in
the laboratory there are many more tests
available outside the U.S than World
Health Organization is recommending this
but at the moment HIV self-testing
really has not caught on too much here
in the United States
so this is our current algorithm that we
do and developed in 2014 and updated uh
by Dr Owen in 2018 and basically we
started off with a combination assay and
if it's negative it's negative if it's
positive now again we don't know if this
is due to antibody to hiv-1 antibody
hiv-2 or the presence of the p24 antigen
seen in an acute HIV infection
so if we were to look at the results
here we would then go to an HIV one two
antibody differentiation assay this now
is the genius assay and if the hiv-1
antibody is positive we have our answer
HIV two antibodies positive one is
negative we have our answer the HIV if
both of them are positive then we sign
it out as HIV antibodies detected most
likely in the United States this would
be due to the presence of nhiv one
infection with some cross reactivity
against hiv2 however depending on where
an individual is from they might be from
an area endemic for hiv2 so this might
be a little bit harder to interpret if
the antibody results are negative or
indeterminate you then go to a nucleic
acid test to a third step
this test now has to be an HIV
qualitative PCR not the viral load test
we'll talk about that more in a minute
and if it's positive this implies that
the original positive result was due to
the presence of p24 antigen in that the
individual actually has an acute hiv-1
infection if it's negative it suggests
that this first result up here was most
likely a false positive or could be a
very early infection with hiv2 again
you'd have to determine if the
individual came from an endemic area for
hiv2
this is a little bit more detail as far
as how you might sign out reports with
um these results and we've really gone
over this I'm not going to um go into
this in more detail again just uh if you
both are positive now again you just say
it's positive for both antibodies
this is even more detail again we're not
going to don't have the time to go over
this in detail but I gave it to you as a
reference this is from the association
of Public Health Laboratories and it
talks about the actual further action so
you can use this as a guide as to what
to recommend to clinicians based on the
reactivities and the of all three of the
so-called combination assay algorithm
tests
so I mentioned differentiating HIV one
from hiv2 infection why would we do this
well first of all there's different
disease progression hiv2 tends to
progress slower to a full-blown age
situation than hiv-1 there are different
treatment regimens for each virus and
also for epidemiological analysis to try
and track a source or track an infection
you'd want to be able to differentiate
hiv-1 from hiv2
however it's really not cost effective
in the United States at this point
improved testing for hiv2 really hasn't
identified more hiv2 in the U.S seen
this date these data from Dr Rowan 187
cases of hiv-2 would uncovered and
reported to the CDC between 2010 and
2017 in the U.S compared to over 325 000
hiv-1 cases so it's far less than one
percent
um of the cases reported are actually
hiv2 and as we all know low prevalence
of H of any lab analyte that we do would
lead to possible false positive tests so
if we're testing low prevalence of HIV
two populations we're going to get false
positive HIV two serologic results
something to keep in mind so again is it
really cost effective to do hiv2 testing
so I'm basically could have HIV viral
load test be done as the third step
instead of the qualitative test most
Labs following HIV patients have a viral
load test on hand very few tests
actually have the volume necessary to
keep an HIV qualitative assay on hand
but the CDC specifically excludes the
viral load tests from the algorithm and
if you talk to them they say Well
they're not doing it the FDA is doing it
the reason being is none of the HIV
viral load tests were submitted to the
FDA to be approved for Diagnostic use
they're approved for monitoring use
therefore they should not be used as
part of a diagnostic regimen however
each lab can validate them as a lab
develop test if they would like to use
it in that purpose and as Dr Rowan says
she can't tell the Physicians what to
order and some docs may be ordering the
viral load in this situation also but
from the lab standpoint you have to
understand that you would be doing it as
off-label and that could get you a
little bit of trouble unless you have
validated it as a lab developed test
there now recently has been one
quantitative acid viral load asset it is
approved for HIV diagnostic use and this
is the Optima hiv-1 assay quantitative
diagnostic acid
so problems with the current algorithm
then it's based on a combination test
method you get a single screening result
for antibody and antigen and both
antigen and antibody confirmatory tests
may be needed this can give you a longer
time to a final result and a second draw
may be necessary if a molecular test is
needed because that may need to be done
on plasma as opposed to serum that was
submitted for the initial testing
and finally it does not include a proper
confirming sequence for the
differentiation assays or fifth
generation assays that provide separate
antibody and antigen results
so what would you do what should you do
if you're doing a differentiation assay
like the bioplex assay
well the what you've seen on this slide
is just my feeling this isn't a formal
recommendation from the CDC or it's not
guidelines at this point but I'm
thinking if only hiv-1 antibody is
positive there's really no need for an
antibody differentiation assay because
you already know that hiv2 antibody is
negative there's really no need for the
diagnostic PCR you should be able to go
right to a viral load in a CD4 count and
monitor this patient
if the p24 antigen is positive and the
antibodies for HIV one and two are
negative there's really no need to do an
antibody differentiation assay again I
would go suggest going right to a viral
load not the CDC hasn't said that but so
what will the CDC do well what they're
doing is asking for data as to how these
assays perform in various clinical
situations so we tried to help them out
with that a couple of years ago where we
did a study looking at all of the
currently available at that particular
time this was done in 2019 we looked at
the fourth and fifth generation assays
that were clinically available
and we compared all of those available
assays on approximately 100 specimens
and what we found out that I don't have
time to go into the data in detail but
the combination and differentiation
assays performed similarly on strongly
positive specimens
and that specific antigen sensitivity
was greater on the bioplex and on the
Allure test it was a rapid test in the
serial conversion panels the bioplex
became positive two to three days
earlier than the other methods weekly
reactive specimens however on one acid
may be negative on other HIV tests
suggesting the possibility of false
positive results something to keep in
mind and makes me really recommend that
you actually look at if you're doing an
Elisa or chemiluminescent type assay or
Multiplex assay that you look at signal
to cut off ratios you look at the values
that come off of that so our main take
on opponent was that the data supported
using more than one antigen antibody
testing method combination method on low
reactive specimens while suggesting that
strongly reactive specimens may not
benefit from being assayed by additional
antibody or antigen testing methods we
feel that patients with strongly
reactive results and one of the
quantitative methods May benefit by
being triage immediately to an
appropriate clinic or physician for
monitoring tests such as CD4 and viral
load
so a proposed changes to the algorithm
that are being considered by Dr Owen in
her groups are basically collecting data
to determine the performance of the
algorithm with nucleic acid testing at
the Second Step In other words getting
rid of the differentiation assay is Step
number two they want to look at
sensitivity specificity cost feasibility
of doing that
currently the data indication of cleric
acid testing at the Second Step does
give reliable diagnoses however this has
not been evaluated in the context of
prep the pre-exposed of prophylaxis or
are the antiretroviral treatment
so this would be one possible algorithm
that could come out of this where you
would actually have an HIV
differentiation diagnostic nucleic acid
test is the Second Step so if they're
positive on a combination or
differentiation assay you then go to the
hiv-12 nucleic acid test and again like
before if you get your results if it's
positive for HIV one you're there
positive for hiv2 positive for both and
we're not really sure with this
particular one and if it's negative
then you want to start thinking maybe we
got to check for antibody here maybe the
patient is antibody but are they truly
infected we go to an antibody
differentiation assay
and another option would be not to do a
differentiation diagnostic nucleic acid
test but just to do a hiv-1 diagnostic
test particularly in the U.S and again
if it's negative then we can start
dealing with or do we have hiv2 antibody
present this I think would be much more
cost effective at least for most of the
United States testing
it's another study that was reported at
the meeting this past March where Dr
Wilson at Tampa General if an ER doc
said that you know was concerned because
if he wanted to do HIV testing in the ER
that the entire algorithm takes longer
than an ER visit and believe me that's
saying something so as we know most of
your visits can last six eight ten hours
or more
and they uh we're using the gene expert
real-time PCR as a second step and this
took 465 minutes which if my math is
correct is a little over seven hours
and a drop of over 2 000 minutes from
using an on-site abdomen PCR however the
gene expert test is not FDA approved but
the abdomen is so you're saving 2 000
minutes by doing this rapid so-called
rapid testaging expert is somewhat rapid
seven hours
um but um the kind you get 100
correlation is what they found with
standard of care so they found this
would be a useful test to do
so I mentioned before I'm very strongly
in favor of using signal to cut off
values and in in clinical history
um in actually interpreting laboratory
results and my corollary for this is not
to do lab testing in a vacuum in the
laboratory we're actually clinical
Consultants we need to be in touch with
our physicians we need to understand the
clinical situation of the patient to be
able to properly inform the physician as
to the how to interpret the acid
so my questions here does a patient with
a strongly positive HIV combination or
differentiation assay really need a
confirmatory test well what we had many
times in my Hospital in Akron Ohio was a
patient admitted with pneumocystitis in
a CD4 count of 50 and a strongly
positive HIV assay why do we need to do
confirming tests we could should be able
to go right to a viral load for that
however if we had an outpatient with no
previous lifestyle high risk activities
then we might be a little bit more
thinking could this be a false positive
maybe we should do confirming tests
and a patient with a low positive HIV
combination differentias they need a
confirming test again the outpatient
with a high-risk lifestyle and hepatitis
C infection
may need be able to go right to a viral
load however the most common false
positive result we had was a pregnant
woman often in a monogamous relationship
that doesn't we didn't always know the
answer to that but pregnant women with a
low positive HIV screening tests were
often negative on a follow-up confirming
test
and so that was a they I figure this
particular clinical situation would
definitely need to undergo confirming
testing
so to summarize now HIV testing has
evolved from the early first generation
viral lysate tests to the fifth
generation differentiation recombinant
antibody antigen tests the combination
of differentiation assays now reduce the
test negative window period so where we
can detect an exposure approximately two
weeks post infection
and the testing algorithm is moving away
from Western blots to the hiv-1
differentiation assay and qualitative
nucleic acid testing methods for com for
confirmation however the current
algorithm does not work well for
differentiation assays or emergency
department practices and moving to a
rapid molecular assay as a second step
May provide better clinical care
finally laboratory clinician
communication can be and I should say
must be a useful adjunct to final result
interpretation
so with that I thank you for your
attention and I turn this back over to
the
bio-red monitors
hello my name is Alfredo Villarreal and
I will be presenting a longitudinal
specificity study performed at a U.S
Public Health laboratory in a high-risk
population
this study expands on original data
previously presented at the 2019 HIV
diagnostic conference
on the bioplex HIV assay with additional
years of data and Analysis
this is a continuation of work with
myself and my colleagues
a brief background the introduction of
combination HIV antigen and antibody
diagnostic screening tests develop over
the last decade have improved the
overall sensitivity and detection of HIV
while sensitivity of HIV combination
type acids has been well described over
the years long-term specificity has not
discussion will examine the specificity
of the bioplex 2200 HIV differentiating
combination assay that was introduced in
the U.S
the bioplex HIV assay detects and
differentiates hiv-1 antigen P20
hiv-1 antibody both groups mno and hiv-2
antibody providing those individual
results as well as an overall screen
result
our objective so in this U.S Public
Health laboratory initial diagnostic
screening for HIV is performed using the
bioplex HIV assay
the laboratory reached out to us to
troubleshoot some observed specificity
issues early in its testing
um poor specificity can lead to higher
false initial reactivity that can be
costly and time consuming for a
laboratory to mitigate as a result
ongoing data was collected to monitor
monthly rolling specificity within any
giving within any given lot
The Collection form is displayed here
and the various possible bioplex HIV
reactivity profits are shown
our methodology so the institution used
the CDC recommended HIV testing
diagnostic algorithm to evaluate all
specimens
um briefly that means that any initially
reactive result was repeated tested and
any repeated reactive results that
follow the algorithm guidelines
supplemental testing was performed on
the Bio-Rad laboratory's genius HIV hiv2
differentiating acids and when necessary
HIV nucleic acid was testing was
performed
over 158 000 serum samples approximately
of which 75 percent were fresh and 25
percent were frozen were submitted to
the public health laboratory for routine
HIV testing between October 2016 and
October 2020.
uh 49 months were tabulated with monthly
detail as shown in the table on the
right and is graphically shown on the
next slide
month to month specificity was
calculated and compared to the bioplex
HIV stated specificity claims
overall specificity was calculated over
the entire period
the Fisher's exact test was used to
determine any significant differences
that is p-value is less than or equal to
0.05 in specificity this was done
monthly as well as over the entire
period
so um our results
um as mentioned we tabulated the data
graphically and it was plotted so that
we could easily identify any trends
the overall specificity during the four
year period was very high at 99.8
percent matching very closely the
bioplex hiv-stated clinical specificity
claim of
99.86 and was well within the stated
confidence intervals of the bioplex HIV
assay
the stated confidence intervals of the
bioplex HIV assay is 99.73 to 999.93 and
is noted by the green bars towards the
top of the graph
individually individual monthly
specificity results range from
98.77 to
99.95 and the CIS are noted by the
whisker style plots in Black
the monthly testing volume is noted in
the by the purple bars and one can see
the effects the covet can pandemic had
on testing volumes during the lockdown
lot changes were also tracked During the
period and is represented by the dashed
blue lines so these are changes in Lots
changes that the facility be used
um in lots a statistically significant
decrease
um is actually shown in the first
um
five of the first 10 month periods
confirming uh what the laboratory saw in
their own observations
um the the decrease is shown as red dots
outside of the confidence intervals and
traced basically back only to one
specific lot
um and and decreasing specificity was
also observed in October of 2019 however
subsequent performance of this lot
normalized after a preventative
maintenance was performed on the system
so digging a little deeper and reviewing
our manufacturing processes we found
that the initial the initial lot was
determined to have a high background
noise that caused the lower specificity
we then adjusted our processes
accordingly
and being a curious person I wanted to
know what the specificity rate would
have been if one removed that lot from
the data
when you remove that lot from the data
the N dropped down to 121 plus thousand
samples and the overall longitudinal
specifically improved to
99.86 with the confidence interval or of
99.84 to 99.88
um and then going back to the complete
data set the overall initial reactivity
was 2.09 percent and upon repeat testing
was reduced to
1.97 percent
of the
3118 repeatedly reactive samples
89.8 or in other words 2800 samples were
confirmed HIV reactive by either
antibody or Nat testing
indicating the positive predictive value
of the bioplex HIV assay
the overalls prevalence was 1.77 percent
and a total of 308 samples did not
confirm giving an excellent overall
false reactivity rate of
0.2 percent
as previously mentioned the overall
specificity was
99.8 percent and this was not
statistically significant from the
bioplex HIV assays as seen in the
Fisher's exact test calculation the
p-value is 0.132
so doing a deeper dive one may notice
that a large portion of the
non-confirmed specimens were hiv-1
antigen only or in conjunction with HIV
one and two undifferentiated antibody
profit profiles
our investigation discovered that most
of those false positives were traced
back to that original lot with the
higher background
so if one excludes that lot from the
analysis it significantly reduces the
number of false positive by 70 percent
bringing the false positivity rate to
0.14 percent
so the positivity relate the positivity
rate for this population in this
location was reduced to 1.66 which
seemed to be in line with the community
that this lab serves
so in summary uh even with the first lot
specificity issues the longitudinal
specificity was very high for the
bioplex HIV assay during the four-year
period and when you remove that lot
increased to 99.86 percent which is
exactly as matched and claimed in the
ifu
[Music]
um
and it's definitely within the
confidence interval of the bioplex HIV
ifu
since the lot changes were also tracked
during that period
um a statistically significant decrease
in specificity was observed in that
five of the first 10 months because then
traced to that one specific law however
subsequent lot performance was greatly
normalized with one month of decreased
specificity noted in October of 2019
attributed to a needed system
maintenance
so in conclusion the bioflex havs has
demonstrated excellent specificity as a
screening diagnostic test and a routine
specimen testings sent to a public
health Laboratory
uh thanks to my colleagues for helping
me with this project and to the public
health lab for allowing this for
allowing us to share this data
and I will pass it on to the next
speaker
hello everyone my name is bayu raval and
I'm a pathology resident at University
of Chicago North Shore program I'm going
to discuss covet antibodies cross
reactivity with bioplex essay what we
encountered in a small study to
investigate the issue
before we go into details let's have
some background here so we have C in
covid and its variance in last two years
and we have developed new tests and
vaccines to deal with it as well
uh although we have performance data our
interference studies as well uh but
still we don't know everything about the
covid yet so I think keeping covert in
mind while you interpret any result or
the test uh it's not a bad idea
and now moving on to the topic this is
what we saw at our North Shore go lab so
in uh second half of the 2021 we
encountered four samples which were
reactive on HIV screen tests and we use
bioplex HIV antigen antibody screening
essay as a screening Tool uh our
flowchart looks like this so whenever we
have HIV reactive screen test we run a
sample in duplicate from the primary
tube and we confirm the sample on genius
if the sample was reactive for antigens
we run HIV are in a PCR or net to
confirm uh the antigen reactivity as
well so the samples were tested on
duplicate from the primary tube on the
same Lot number of the bioplex HIV essay
and the results we found were concordant
with the previous results
so before we go into further testing
part let me tell you briefly about the
bioid sa we use uh it's a
differentiating combination screening
essay which qualitatively detects and
differentiates between the HIV p24
antigen and HIV one and two antibodies
uh essay results for each nhiv analyte
reflects as index where less than one is
a non-reactive and one or more than one
is given as reactive
in certain situations it happens that
hiv-1 and hiv-2 antibody both have
indexes more than one so in those
scenarios if hiv-1 antibody indexes at
least five four the HIV 20 body index
the system output will be HIV one
reactive with the index and HIV 2 as
non-reactive same applies for HIV to
antibody if it is five-fold higher than
the hiv-1 antibodies so then HIV 2 will
be given as reactive with the index and
hiv-1 non-reactive
uh certain scenarios uh are like when
you have HIV one and two antibody
indexes positive like a reactive more
than one but the difference is not
five-fold between them so then the
system output will be reactive
undifferentiated for HIV one and two
antibodies and the indexes will be given
as well
and this is the table showing our four
positive samples for HIV so P one to
four are the patient samples uh the
second column shows the analytes and the
top one HIV antigen antibody uh analyte
will be reactive if any of the analyte
is reactive the next two columns
indicate the indexes for the analytes
for the first sample P1 both antibodies
are reactive HIV one and two but the
difference between them is not five-fold
uh one has 5.9 and the other is 3.34 so
the difference is not five-fold and
that's why the result came as reactive
undifferentiated the same thing applies
for the other three samples as well so
the difference between uh the indexes of
the HIV one and two antibodies were not
five volt they were given as reactive
undifferentiated in addition to that the
antigens were positive too so for the
second sample the index for the HIV one
antigen was 33. uh the third sample had
14.8 and the last sample had the index
of 9.75 for HIV one antigen
and this is the table showing in-house
Conformity testing uh so our four
samples were tested on biodegenius HIV
as well as on the net and the results
were negative for both uh indicating
those samples as a false positive
samples
this kind of HIV reactivity pattern uh
in a short period of time for our
patient population is little bit unusual
so we did a retrospective look at our
Quality Control Data which was in place
and then we looked at the patient
histories uh as well which were very
diverse except for the one thing uh
which was a recent covet vaccination by
Pfizer
so to dig deeper uh we reached out to
bioret for a potential cross-reactivity
of covet antibodies with the HIV essay
we sent de-identified samples to buy red
for further workup uh they verified the
results with different lots of bioflex
and that they confirmed the samples on
genius as well the results were found to
be concordant with in-house results
indicating those samples as a false
positive samples
so then we decided to do a small study
and the aim was to determine the cause
of false positivity for our four
in-house samples and evaluate the
potential role of covet infection or in
vaccination antibodies in the false
reactivity of those samples
we made three cohorts to evaluate the
covert antibodies cross reactivity with
HIV screening essay samples for all the
cohorts were acquired from external
vendor and they were received in Frozen
State they were thought before the
testing
cohort one so cohort one included 121
naturally infected covet patient samples
and we use this to evaluate the covet
antibodies cross reactivity with HIV
screening essay in naturally infected
patients the patient's age range from 29
to 77 years and they were collected
between 21 to 133 days after the symptom
onset the samples were evaluated on
bioplex HIV essay and the positive ones
were confirmed on genius HIV
results for cohort 1 so out of 121
naturally infected patient samples uh
two samples were reacted positive for
HIV one antibody on bioplex HIV essay
and both the samples did conform on
genius HIV as positive results uh
indicating them as a true positive
samples so we can say that we did not
find any apparent cross reactivity with
natural infected patient samples
uh moving on to the cohort to use so in
cohort 2 we had 91 known cold vaccinated
patient samples and we use this cohort
to evaluate covet antibodies cross
reactivity with HIV screening essay in
vaccinated patients uh we included 34
jnj 26 visor and 31 modern vaccinated
patient samples in cohort 2. the
patient's age ranged from 33 to 89 years
and they were collected from 7 to 124
days after vaccination
ah we performed bioplex HIV essay on 91
samples and the positive ones were
tested on bioregenius HIV essay
and now results for the cohort juice so
out of 91 two samples uh were reactive
on bioplex HIV essay out of the two one
was a jnj vaccinated sample and the
other was Modern a vaccinated patient
sample
and this is a table showing those two
reactive vaccinated patient samples so
the jnj sample was reactive for antigen
with the index of 1.87 and the moderna
sample was reactive for HIV one and two
antibodies and which was given as
reactive undifferentiated uh because the
difference in the index was less than
five-fold uh our four samples where
Pfizer vaccinated but here uh none of
the files are vaccinated samples was
found to be reactive
both jnj and modern are reactive samples
uh were tested on genius as well which
was uh non-reactive
unfortunately we did not had sufficient
quantities of the sample to test for Nat
in antigen positive case uh so the true
positivity cannot be ruled out here uh
the index here was 1.8 and given the
index is very low uh we presumed it to
be a false positive result
so in summary cohort 2 had two reactive
samples on bioplex which did not confirm
on genius HIV so they are false positive
HIV results on bioplex and since we only
had two samples tested false positive
for HIV uh we did not find any apparent
cross reactivity with vaccinated patient
samples
moving on to the cohort 3 now uh cohort
3 included 580 presumed normal patient
samples uh the samples were acquired
from external vendor after 2019 and the
patient's age raised from 13 to 97 years
old the samples were evaluated on bio
Red starscope 2 IGG essay bioplex HIV
antigen antibody assay and reactive
samples for HIV conformed on genius
essay
and before we move on to the next slide
let me tell you a little bit about the
biorexr scope to IGG essays so
um it is a IGG antibody essay which
detects IGG against receptor binding
domain uh Spike one two and nuclear
capsid proteins of the covid virus it
can use serum and plasma both uh the
positive results indicate a recent uh or
a prior infection or an acquired
immunity from vaccination
um it's a CE marked essay and it is
available in Europe uh currently in USA
it is not available
and now uh results for cohort 3 so out
of 580 presumed normal samples 393
samples uh tested positive on bioret
SARS Cove 2 iggsa meaning they have a
covet antibody in the system
uh and nine out of 580 samples found to
be reactive on bioplex HIV antigen
antibody SC out of that nine seven
samples were reactive for HIV one
antibody and two samples where HIV
antigen reactive ah on further testing
on genius uh the seven samples confirmed
reactive indicating them as true
positive and two samples uh which are
which were HIV antigen reactive did not
conform on genius uh below is the table
showing two false positive samples uh
both were antigen reactive with low
indexes like 1.32 and 2.0
um unfortunately we did not had
sufficient sample quantity to test for
Nat in both the antigen positive cases
uh so here
um true positivity cannot be ruled out
but given the indexes are very low uh we
presume them to be a false positive
samples
and uh there is one more thing to notice
here that one of the samples was uh
sarskov 2 IGG positive and the other
sample was ask of 2 IGG negative
um and this is the flowchart showing uh
how we divided the samples in the cohort
three uh so we had 580 presume normal
samples in the beginning and we did star
scope 2 IGG on 580 samples uh then
divided them into positive antibody and
negative antibody group so in the
positive antibody group we had 393
samples and in the negative we had 187
samples
uh after that we did bioplex HIV uh
essay on uh all the samples and further
divided them into reactive and
non-reactive uh groups uh in the
positive antibody group we had eight
reactive samples and in the negative
antibody group we had one uh HIV
reactive sample uh we did Biore genius
HIV on all the reactive samples and it
looks like uh that in the positive
antibody group we had seven reactive or
seven positive on bioregenius and one uh
reactive sample did not confirm on
biored genius so then we can say in the
positive antibody group we had seven
true positive and one false positive
samples uh moving to the negative
antibody cohort we had one bioplex HIV
positive sample which did not conform on
bio genius indicating that as a false
positive
sample in the negative antibody group
so finally we have one false positive
HIV antigen reactive sample in covid
antibody positive group as well as in
the covet antibody negative group
we also did feature exact test for
calculation of p-value for sensitivity
and specificity of the bioplex HIV essay
in covet positive and negative antibody
groups the p-value less than 0.05 was
considered to be significant the values
are like this uh the p-value for the
sensitivity is 1 and specificity was
0.5466 which was not statistically
significant
so in conclusion the results from all
three cohorts showed no correlation
between the covet antibodies and false
positive HIV screening results
we also did a data analysis at an
institution for bioplex HIV essay
specificity uh and we found it to be
99.87 to 99.89 percent for that specific
time period
um which is within the manufacturer's
claimed range and now coming back to our
in-house four samples so the false
positivity of those four samples were
likely due to various residual
non-specific immunoassay binding
feel free to send me an email if you
have any questions and thank you so much
for listening
thank you are you Alfredo and Tom for
your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
at the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
what troubleshooting was done to
determine that the October increase in
false positive results was due to an
instrument problem rather than a test
reagent problem
hi this is Alfredo um I'll go ahead and
answer that question
um so in short when when we received the
uh the incident report in October was
brought to our attention
the uh the first thing that we did was
obtain the system log files and after
reviewing those we we noticed that there
was an increased value in the detector
noise and then when we checked to see
when the loss preventative maintenance
was performed
um it was um it was um past due so then
we decided that we would perform
preventative maintenance and we ran the
system through a series of tests to
ensure that the background was removed
and we went down this road mostly
because we saw that the first data point
of that particular lot was just fine in
there in their system and when we
removed and when we did the needed
maintenance
um that the data went back to what I
would call our normal state
all right thank you next question
is it cost effective to use HIV
molecular diagnostic testing and low
risk low prevalence populations
so unfortunately uh Tom and Dr Alexander
has not been able to
to join us and um I would have deferred
this this question to him
um so um I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
have to just pass on this particular
question and and maybe he'll be able to
join us in a little bit if it's possible
all right great
um next question
please define recent in terms of time
frame between date of Pfizer coveted
vaccination versus collection date of
HIV samples
I'm assuming this is in reference to Dr
raval's presentation
um the act at the end of the day excuse
me
at the end of the day
the information is
um not really available available to us
in detail but it was um stated in the
presentation that it was 7 to 124 days
after vaccination if you would like to
reach out to us directly we can go ahead
and look up that data as best we can
all right great thank you
uh next question
um
was this study conducted on patients who
had completed the full vaccination
series or partial series
right that's a great question
um
so we we don't uh as well we don't
actually have that uh full information
it was purchased from a vendor so we
don't actually know exactly if they were
you know had the booster shot or
um or or not on the initial series was
there as a requirement but we didn't
know if we actually had the booster
information or not we can check but we
actually believe that there's a mixture
depending on when of course the uh the
uh the samples were collected
all right thank you
next question
have other vendors showed any issues
with cross-reactivity in their assays
for HIV
um so the reason why this was brought up
um initially for
um
the facility at North Shore University
was
um there was some some editorials that
had come out with respects to other
vendors having some initial issues
um I won't I won't say who because I'm a
buyer ad employee and but Dr raval was
going to go ahead and do some additional
investigations on that and her intent is
to provide additional editorials that
could be
submitted for your for your all review
all right thank you
um next question
um oh I'm sorry we are actually out of
time with that final question
um thank you again pay you Alfredo and
Tom for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor biorad
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone and
goodbye